المترجم: Sundos Hammoud
المدقّق: fatima ma
صباح الخير وشكراً لدعوتي إلى TEDx
وأشكر القائمين،
وأشكر الجامعة العربية الدوليّة،
طُلب مني أن أتكلم قليلاً عن تجربتي
الشخصية، عندها في هذه اللحظة فكرت
ماهي تجربتي الشخصية ؟
حاولت أن أُفكر
صراحة؛ وجدت أن ملخص حياتي هما كلمتين:
"الإصرار والعزيمة".
كنت مصرّاً على شيء، بالرغم من
كل العقبات التي واجهتني في حياتي.
قد يستغرب أحدكم أنني عندما كنتُ طفلاً
سألوني ماذا سأكون في المستقبل؟
فأجبت طبيب عصبية.
طبعاً لم يخطر في بالي أن طفل صغير
ما الذي يجول في خاطره،
لكن على ما يبدو كانت هذه
ومضةً من المستقبل
جاءتني في صغري.
فعندما دخلت المدرسة
كنت قد قررت أن أكون شخصاً متميزاً
في أي فرع أدخله،
كان هذا قراري،
بغض النظر عن الفرع الذي سأختاره.
حقيقةً كان هدفي الحصول على
أعلى علامة في ااشهادة الثانوية.
وهذا ما حدث.
بعدها فكرت ما هو أصعب اختصاص؟
هو الطب.
فدخلت كلية الطب.
بعدها تساءلت ما أصعب اختصاص في الطب؟
كان العصبيّة؛ فدخلت العصبية.
كانت قرارتي غريبةً نوعاً ما
لكنني كنتُ أُفكربهذا الأسلوب.
طبعاُ عندما يدخل الإنسان في هذا المجال
دائماً يُفكر كيف سينجح بهذا الإختصاص؟
لا شك بأن أي شخص يحاول القيام بأمر ما
فإنه سيواجه الكثير من الصِعاب والعوائق.
فمثلاً عندما دخلت كلية الطب
قلت أن أصعب شيءٍ فيه هو شهادة من إنكلترا
اسمها MRCP
فقررت أن أسافر وأحصل عليها.
وبعد تخرجي من كلية الطب،
كان هدفي الذهاب إلى بريطانيا،
فبدأت بمراسلة بريطانيا وكانت أولى العقبات
أن بريطانيا رفضت طلبي لأنها صعبة جداً
والدخول إليها صعبٌ أيضاً
فحاولوا منعي من القدوم بالأساس.
لذلك أصررت على الذهاب.
العقبة الثانية كانت الأهل،
أنا وحيد لأهلي وكانت صعوبات عائلية،
لماذا تريد أن تسافر وتتركنا،
لكني أصررت على الذهاب،
هذا أيضاً أحد العوائق.
الأمر الثالث:
عندما قررت السفر إلى بريطانيا
انقطعت العلاقات الديبلوماسية مع بريطانيا
بسبب حادثة طيران،
عندها قلت أن الأمر خرج من يدي
وأصبح الحل بيد الله سبحانه.
لكن شاء القدر أن أعرف شخصاً له
علاقاته في وزارة الخارجية
بعدما انقطعت العلاقات
طلبت بريطانيا بطاقة ترجّي
من الحكومة السورية لنظيرتها البريطانية
لأحصل على التأشيرة،
قلت لنفسي من أنا حتى تترجى الحكومة السورية
نظريتها البريطانية لأحصل على التأشيرة؟
فذهبت إلى موظف في الخارجيّة
جلست عنده من الثامنة صباحاً
وكل فترة كان يسألني سؤالاً،
علاماتي في الثانوية،
ماذا درست ؟
ما هو معدلك في السنة الأولى؟
كان يتصل به ويزوره أشخاص مهمون في البلد،
وكلهم يريدون بطاقات ترجّي
فيجيبهم هذه بطاقة إذلال للحكومة السورية،
ونحن لا نعطي بطاقات إذلال.
جلست عنده من الثامنة صباحًا
إلى الواحدة ظهراً
وكل فترة يسألني سؤال عن حياتي.
آخر الأمر طلب هويتي
وأعطاني بطاقة ترجّي،
عندها استغربت وقلت له
أُريد ان أسألك سؤالاً
لماذا لم تعطيهم بطاقات ترجي وأنا أعطيتني؟
أجابني أنت مجتهد على
نفسك ولن أضيّع مستقبلك.
وكان هذا الإصرار الثاني
والأمر الذي فتح لي الطريق.
طبعاً بعد عودتي من بريطانيا
بحثت عنه وشكرته.
لم أشكره فحسب، فبعد أسبوع أصيب بمرض
كان يعاني من مشكلة مرضية ولم يعرف أحد
كيف يساعده وأنا عالجته منها،
عندها قال لي أرأيت كيف أنني كنت على حق؟
فإذا كان الشخص في موقع مسؤولية
وقادر على حل بعض الأمور فيجب أن يحلها.
بعد وصولي إلى بريطانيا كانت صدمة الحضارة.
عندما يسافر الشخص من سوريا إلى بريطانيا
ويواجه أولئك العلماء
ففي أول أسبوع عانيت من صدمة الحضارة.
وأول ما واجهته كان اللغة
فهم يتكلمون بسرعة،
كانوا يتكلمون الإنكليزية وأنا لا أزال
أتعلم كيفية تركيب الجمل،
ولغتي الأصلية فرنسية وأتعلم الإنكليزية.
كان هنالك طبيب يدعى "نايتنجيل"
طلب مني الجلوس وسألني
يا محمد ما مشكلتك؟
فشرحت له وضعي
أنني في سوريا درست الطب بالعربية
ولغتي فرنسية
واشتكيت له عن هذا الامر مطولاً،
فبعد مضي قرابة عشر دقائق،
وهو يسمعني ويهز برأسه،
قال لي هل تظن أن أحداً ما
سيرحمك في هذا البلد؟
لا أحد سيرحمك.
أحسست كأنه صفعني،
فكلامه صحيح، ما علاقته بمشاكلي؟
أنا أريد أن أصبح شخصًا مهمًا،
ما علاقتهم هم؟
بعدها صرت أعمل وأدرس،
وركّزت على اللغة،
في الأسبوع التالي طلب مني
أن أقدم له حالة طبية
وبعد أن قدمتها سألني
?Are you the same mohammad
أنت محمد نفسه الذي كان منذ أسبوع؟
كان هو من ساعدني على استيعاب الوضع الجديد
فسابقاً كنت أشتكي كثيرًا
ولكن هنا لا مكان للشكوى.
بعدها بدأت بالتحضير لإمتحان MRCP
وهنا كما تعلمون يمر في حياة الإنسان
أشخاص أو مواقف يتعلم منها دروسًا.
وقد تعلمت درسًا آخر من إمرأة من هونغ كونغ،
كانت معنا في المستشفى،
سألتني كيف تدرس؟
أجبتها أعمل نهاراً وأدرس ليلاً وأحل أسئلة.
سألتني متى وقت الامتحان؟
فأجبتها في العاشرة صباحاً.
قالت فإذاً ستجيب على الأسئلة
في الوقت الذي يكون فيه دماغك نائماً
لا يحل الأسئلة،
يجب أن تعوّد نفسك على حل نموذج أسئلة
بشكل يومي في وقت الامتحان
حتى يتعود دماغك على حل
الأسئلة في وقت الامتحان،
لأنك عوّدت دماغك
على العمل ليلاً وليس نهارًا،
لذا ستجد صعوبة في حل الأسئلة.
حقيقةً كانت نصيحتها بمحلها،
وصرت أحل نماذج الأسئلة يومياً
في العاشرة صباحاً.
وعندما دخلت إلى الامتحان أيضاً،
طبعاً فحص الـ MRCP مرعب،
لكن شائت الظروف أن أكون مع الشخص
المسؤول عن امتحان الـ MRCP
فأعطاني نصيحتين لن أنساهما ما حييت،
قال: أنظر! أنا أمتحنك منذ 3 شهور وأنت تجيب
أنت في الواقع تعرف أكثر مني
مما عزز ثقتي بنفسي،
لكن الفرق أنني أنا من يسأل وأنت من يُجيب
فأنا إما أسمح لك بالنجاح أو لا.
قال لي لا تخف، معلوماتك جيدة جداً
قال أيضاً: أنت تتكلم بصوت ناعم
مما يعطي انطباع بأنك
خائف أو لا تملك ثقة بنفسك،
ارفع صوتك،
فذهبت إلى الإمتحان بمعنويات مرتفعة،
انظر إلى من سيمتحنوني بأنني
أعرف وأفهم أكثر منهم،
وصرت أرفع صوتي،
أحياناً المزاح في الإمتحان
يأتي بنتيجة إيجابية،
فدخلت إلى أهم فحص وأدقّ
قسم اسمه "short cases"
بأول قسم ورغم صعوبته،
وبما أن اسمي محمد شحادة آغا،
فسألني are you agha khan؟
فأجبته لا، أنا شحادة آغا
لو أنا آغا خان لكنت ملياردير
ولما خضت هذا الفحص المُرعب.
فضحك وقال:
so, you're not rich
فقلت له أنا لستُ غنيًا،
لكن جدي من جهة أبي كان غنيًا.
فسألني أين ذهب جدك بأمواله؟
فقلت على النساء.
(ضحك)
فضحك بشدة وقال
let's stop and start the exam
عندها تنفست الصعداء
لأنني كنت خائفاً أكثر منه،
ولكنني بهذه المحادثة القصيرة
معه ارتاحت أعصابي،
فامتُحنت ونجحت بتوفيق من الله.
الخطوة التي بعدها
كانت الحصول على الـ MRCP
بعد نجاحي صُدمت، فماذا علي أن أعمل الآن؟
انتهت اللعبة والآن ماذا عليّ أن أفعل؟
ماذا سأفعل بحياتي الآن؟
قلت لنفسي لقد سبق وقررت
أن أكون متميزاً في حياتي،
فلابد أن أكون متميزاً حتى في اختصاصي،
وبالتالي بدأت مشواري مع العصبية
بعد أن بدأت وفي أحد المقابلات
التي ذهبت إليها
كانت بمدينة Derby
أخبروني أنه في مدينة Derby
يوجد جاليات تكره العرب
فلم أرغب بالذهاب إلى تلك المقابلة
فالتفت عائداً في منتصف الطريق،
بعدها راجعت نفسي وبما أنني وصلت لمنتصف
الطريق قررت المتابعة،
وعندما وصلت وجدت 25 شخصاً سيقابلون
من أجل 4 وظائف
عندها قلت لن انتظر 3 ساعات وهممت بالخروج،
عندها التقيت بشخص انكليزي كنا نعمل معاً
ودعاني لشرب القهوة،
ومن ثم دخلت إلى المقابلة،
وهنا كانت الصدمة،
كنت ناحجاً بامتحاناتي وحاصل على الـ MRCP
وكانوا 20 شخص وبدؤوا بسؤالي عن أمورٍ طبية
مع أنها مقابلة عمل وليست فحص علمي،
وأنا ناجح بالإمتحان مؤخراً.
سألوني أسئلة طبية كثيرة،
فاستغربت،
ثم سألني آخرهم كم طالب
طب كان في دفعتك في سوريا؟
ظننت أنه يعرف الوضع في سوريا،
(ضحك)
أجبته 500
قال يا إلهي 500!
واستخف بقدراتي العلمية
شن علي هجوماً قوياً
ثم سألني كم واحد تخرج؟
لا أعلم كم شخصاً تخرج
لكن أجبته برقم مميز لأظل قادراً على تذكره
فقلت له 333
(ضحك)
حتى الآن أذكره
قال يا إلهي 333!
بريطانيا كلها تخرج 200 طبيب بالسنة،
واستمر بهجومه
ولكني بالأصل لم أكن أريد الوظيفة،
عندها قلت له: تعتقد أننا غير دارسين
وغير مؤهلين
أليس كذلك؟
فقال أنا لا أقصد هذا،
قلت له بلى تقصد
إذا كنت تعتقد أني غير مؤهل للوظيفة
فلا تطلب مني القدوم وتقابلني من الأساس،
وتابعت؛ أنتم تسألوني بأمور طبية
أنا نجحت حديثاً بالـ MRCP
ومعلوماتي أقوى وأفضل من معلوماتكم جميعاً
فقال لي نحن لا نريد أن نهينك،
فقلت بلى لقد أهنتموني،
وخرجت من القاعة،
وهممت بالعودة،
والتقيت ثانية بالرجل الإنكليزي
ودعاني لشرب القهوة مرةً ثانية
(ضحك)
شربنا قهوة مرة أخرى
وبقي حوالي 20 شخصاً أنهوا مقابلاتهم بسرعة
بعدها نادوا على أسماء المقبولين وكنت منهم
قاموا بعرض الوظيفة عليّ مرةً أُخرى
هم يعرضونها على الشخص
مرة أخرى لأنه قد لا يقبل،
أجبته نعم سآخذها،
أصبح الأمر تحدي بالنسبة لي
فقال ستبدأ بـ 1 / آب
فقلت لا سأبدأ بـ 8 / آب
لأفرض شخصيتي قلت 8 آب،
فوافق.
وكانت من أفضل الوظائف التي حصلت عليها.
حيث أتاحوا لي بعدها القيام ببحث علمي
والعديد من الأشياء الرائعة في حياتي.
هنالك شيء آخر مهم بحياتي،
أنني عندما سافرت إلى بريطانيا،
-كل شخص يجب أن يقوم بما فعلت-
أحضرت بطاقة صغيرة
وكتبت عليها مبادئ حياتي.
أحد تلك المبادئ كان
"كن قوياً في العلم يهابك كل الناس "
عندما يكون الإنسان قوياً بالعلم،
يهابه الجميع ويحترمونه.
هذا أمر بغاية الأهمية.
المبدأ الثاني:
"ازهد في المال يأتيك"
اعمل لتحقيق هدفك وليس لكسب المال،
والمال سيأتيك مع الوقت.
كان هذا المبدأ الثاني في حياتي.
ثالثاً كان "الأخلاق والمُثل العُليا"
فأنا دائمًا أعمل بأخلاقي،
وغير مستعد للتنازل عن أخلاقي
مهما كانت الظروف.
كان هذا أحد مبادئي.
والمبدأ الآخر كان
أن أكون بارّاً بأهلي وبالمحيطين فيّ
وهذا أمر قمت به طوال حياتي،
ولا أزال أقوم به.
هذه المبادئ والقيم مهمة جداً
في حياة الإنسان
أحد الأشياء التي أود ذكرها أيضاً عن حياتي
والتي تعبر عن التعب الذي
واجهته وعزيمتي القوية،
عندما ذهبت إلى بريطانيا تنقلت
بين عدة وظائف،
فكل 6 أشهر أتنقل إلى عمل جديد.
فسألت مشرفي لماذا كل هذه
التنقلات كل ستة أشهر؟
فنحن لا نلبث أن نصل إلى المدينة
ونعمل في المشفى لشهر أو شهرين
ثم تبدأ عملية التقديم إلى وظائف
جديدة وننتقل إلى مدينة جديدة.
أجابني أنت الآن لا تعلم قيمة هذا،
لكن بعد أن تكبر
ستكون قد شاهدت نفس المرض
وقد عالجه 10 أشخاص
ولكل منهم طريقة مختلفة،
وبالنهاية يكون لك طريقتك الخاصة.
وعندما تتعلم هذه الطريقة ستمارسها بحياتك
لأنك رأيت 10 أشخاص يطبقونها.
لكن يوماً ما قد يأتيك مريض ولا تنجح طريقتك
فوراً ستتذكر طُرق العلاج العشرة الأخرى
فتبحث عن طريقة أخرى استخدمها شخصٌ غيرك.
وهكذا ستتعلم.
وفعلاً كان هذا شيئاً مهماً بحياتي.
فتعلمت من كل طريقة، فأحياناً يأتي المريض
ولا يستفيد على طريقة علاجي،
ولا يُبدي أي تحسّن.
فوراً أتذكر الطرق العلاجية والوسائل
الآخرى.
اتبع أحد أساتذتي طريقاً علاجية
أنه كان عندما يأتيه مريض حالته
معقدة يوقف له كل الأدوية.
كنت أخاف، ولكنه كان يقول لي
هذا ما عليك فعله عندما يأتيك
مريض حالته معقدة ولم يتحسن.
فلربما يكون دواؤه سبب مرضه.
فأوقف الأدوية وراقب الحالة
بعدها تعيد إعطائه الأدوية
واحداً تلو الآخر.
وفعلاً أستخدم أنا هذه الطريقة
أحياناً وأجدها ناحجة جداً.
لأنه أحياناً تختلط الأمور على الطبيب
وأخيراً أحب أن أتحدث في ختام كلامي
عن كيف أن التجارب تعلم الإنسان.
في أحد المرات زارني مريض
يُعاني وهن عضلي وخيم
وجربنا أنا وأستاذي كل
الطرق العلاجية الممكنة،
وأعطيناه كورتزيون لـ 100 ملغ،
أزلنا غدة التيموس،
قمنا بفصل بلازما،
كل الطرق العلاجية المعروفة،
وفشلنا!
فكل يوم كان يقول لي لا أستطيع البلع.
وفي نهاية المطاف طلب مني الاتصال
بشخص يدعى "نيوزم ديفيس" في لندن
مختص بالوهن العضلي الوخيم،
وطلب مني أن أرى ما رده.
فاتصلت به، وسألني إن اتبعنا
الإجراءات المعروفة فقلت نعم.
فطلب مني أن أرسل المريض إليه.
وكانت أول مرة في حياتي
أُرسل فيها مريضاً من مشفى لآخر.
ذهب المريض إليه وبعد أسبوعين
اتصل الدكتور المعالج
وطلب أن أُعيد المريض.
عاد المريض وقد شفي تماماً!
وعندما سألت المريض عما حدث
قال لي اسأل الطبيب،
فقال أنتم قُمتم بالعلاج اللازم،
وأعطيتموه جرعة كورتيزون 100 ملغ،
أما نحن فزدنا الجرعة 5 ملغ،
أي 105 ملغ، فشُفي.
(ضحك)
عندما عُدت إلى سوريا كانت أول حالة
عاينتها لمريضة تعاني وهن عضلي وخيم
كانت على المُنفّسة،
وتُعالج بـ كوزتيزون 60 ملغ،
فطلبت منهم أن يزودوا الجرعة 5 ملغ،
فشُفيت!
(ضحك)
فالخبرة والحالات التي تمر مع
الإنسان كتجارب في حياته
يطبقها ويستفيد منها أحياناً
ولوكانت أموراً صعبة أو مشاكل معقدة.
أشكركم من جديد على دعوتي إلى هنا
للحديث عن بعض التجارب التي مرت بحياتي.
وشكراً لكم.
(تصفيق)